[Applaudissements]
nous ouvrons aujourd'hui une nouvelle
page de l'histoire de la vienne
nous avons un contrat de confiance avec
les habitants ici
tous ensemble nous sommes liés par la
passion de notre département et l'avenir
de nos concitoyens ils attendent de nous
que nous soyons à la hauteur des enjeux
de demain
nous venons récemment deux traversé deux
crises la première qui sanitaire nous en
sortons à peine qui a durement touché
notre société par sa violence à la fois
humaines par les décès qu'elle a causés
mais aussi par les soucis psychologiques
autour de cette crise et nous oblige
aujourd'hui à réfléchir différemment
elle nous oblige à reconsidérer nos
priorités elle nous oblige à affiner nos
orientations politiques et notre
organisation
je profite de ce moment pour rendre
hommage comme je lé déjà fait à
plusieurs reprises au personnel soignant
qui ont fait face et qui font encore
face avec un engagement sans limite et
un dévouement sans faille
je souhaite aussi félicité et remercié
les équipes du département qui ont
maintenu l'activité du conseil
départemental
quoi qu'il en coûte dans des conditions
parfois difficiles
la deuxième crise est celle d'un record
un record d'abstention
notre démocratie est malade plus de deux
français sur trois ont boudé les urnes
lors du premier tour
oui un contexte anxiogène une campagne
confiné mais là n'est sans doute pas la
raison nos concitoyens n'ont plus
confiance
loin de tout feu fatalité notre défi
sera celui de leur redonner la foi dans
l'action publique dans nos projets dans
notre volonté de faire avancer la vienne
c'est pourquoi j'ai décidé de nommer un
conseiller départemental à la
citoyenneté
aujourd'hui je mesure l'immense
responsabilité qui est la mienne celle
de rassembler autour d'un projet
ambitieux et d'une vision que nous avons
pour la vienne nos priorités sont
claires les solidarités
nous continuerons nos politiques envers
les plus fragiles du plus jeunes aux
aînés
nous resterons dans tous les domaines
engagé malgré les baisses de dotations
de l'état
l'aménagement et le développement
durable du territoire
nous serons toujours les premiers
partenaires des collectivités dans leurs
projets nous serons mobilisés pour le
réseau routier et le déploiement de la
fibre pour tous à l'horizon 2025
nous engagerons une politique durable
dans tous les domaines c'est une
priorité l'éducation la jeunesse et
l'épanouissement de tous les publics à
travers nos politiques éducatives pour
les collèges mais aussi pour toutes nos
compétences partagées sport culture
tourisme etc 2022 verra naître
l'aboutissement de plusieurs grands
projets portés par la majorité
départementale
l'arena futuroscope bien sûr tant
attendu celui du futuroscope 2 qui va
donner un nouveau souffle à la
locomotive touristique et économique de
la vienne
le 35e collège à vouneuil sous biard
l'historial du poitou et tant d'autres
quatre projets me tiennent à coeur pour
ce nouveau mandat
porter une nouvelle ambition pour le
développement durable accompagné notre
jeunesse plus fortement par la création
d'un guichet unique jeunesse fait
renaître le projet de territoire
numérique éducatif sur la technopole
sujet sur lequel je travaille aux côtés
d'henry et des équipes depuis plusieurs
mois engagé les états généraux du
handicap pour faire plus
et mieux avec vosges entend orienter
notre action en transversalité
ce travail permettra de mener des
politiques publiques efficientes au
service de tous nos concitoyens et en
collégialité garantie de la cohérence et
de la réussite de nos actions du travail
de l'action de la proximité de la
réactivité pour la vienne tout cela avec
bon sens
j'irai à la rencontre de chacun et
chacune d'entre vous en particulier les
vice-présidents et présidents
responsables de commissions dès cet été
pour définir ensemble une feuille de
route précise elle sera garante d'un
travail dans la durée notre
administration sera ensuite chargé
d'engager très rapidement la mise en
oeuvre de nos politiques publiques
je veux que nous réussissions ensemble
je veux travailler en équipe et
multiplier nos énergies au service de la
vienne comme président je n'imposerai
pas je rassemblerai notre assemblée doit
rester celle du dialogue de l'action au
plus proche de nos concitoyens ce n'est
pas qu'une assemblée politique c'est une
assemblée pragmatique notre département
que je sillonne en tant que président
depuis plus de six mois
regorge d'atouts de pépites dans tous
les domaines nous devons être à la
hauteur des enjeux de territoire
notre adn celui de la proximité devra
constamment d'idées notre action je
défendrai cette collectivité avec force
parce que le département a montré plus
que jamais en particulier pendant la
crise sanitaire son utilité au service
des habitants
je défendrai avec vous l'échelon
départemental
garant de la décentralisation la
décentralisation c'est l'action nous
relèverons ensemble ce défi
mes chers collègues je suis résolument
engagés pour les projets pour l'avenir
pour la vienne
c'est un nouveau chapitre qui s'ouvre
aujourd'hui c'est une fierté et une
responsabilité
nous avons un devoir d'efficacité ce qui
compte c'est de servir tous les
habitants de la vienne en accompagnant
leur quotidien et en préparant l'avenir
je veux que nous ayons ici de l'ambition
de la créativité pour favoriser le
développement de notre territoire
réfléchissons ensemble pour aller plus
loin on état d'esprit est celui d écoute
et de la bienveillance active à l'égard
de chacun et chacune d'entre vous j'ai
confiance en vous j'ai confiance en
notre projet j'ai confiance en la vienne
merci encore et au travail
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]